je vous parlais au début de ce journal
de ce drame qui s'est déroulé tout à
l'heure cet après-midi dans une cité hlm
de saint denis un homme a tiré sur des
enfants parce qu'il est excédé par le
bruit
il ya eu deux blessés bien voici le
reportage de isabelle bechler cité de la
courtille à samedi à dimanche après midi
très lourd les enfants jouent entre les
immeubles certains font des tours à
mobylette il fait chaud et leur âge ne
se décide pas à venir
la petite fatima était là jeudi avec les
autres derrière une fenêtre un homme qui
a débuté mais revoit et là bas et
afrique et messieurs tête car sans ça
plutôt premiers mois après il faut les
monter tous ont mis le pied sur
l'apparence faire et puis après ça ne
fait pas monter chez ce après et son
fils arthur le monsieur y laissa feu il
a sorti un suicide
il a qui paraît faux après ils sont
partis après une minute après la féte
échange ce qu'il faut et sow après la
prière et valier sortie l'avenir et une
fois à vraiment chic où je me suis
offert la passe après j'ai été faire la
page et oeuvrer avec marc santerre et
prochain contre le maillon de chez péché
ma personne c'est de cette fenêtre que
monsieur tu avais la trentaine a blessé
les deux enfants de moins de 10 ans il
vivait là avec sa mère une femme âgée
handicafé on le connaissait peu car ils
ne sortaient pas beaucoup à peine pour
faire des courses mais surtout il était
tard hier c'est un homme en fait je peux
pas dire si buvait lance enfin je
pourrais pas le dire parce que la
société veut dire c'est quand on sortait
en 10 parties renvoyées qu'il avait là
les chapeaux de cow-boy gros ceinturons
bottes de cowboy enfin hier semblait
plutôt correct quelque chose il ne veut
pas d'enfant cet homme là où il
s'occupait de sa mère qui était infirme
et je ne connaissais pas comme quelqu'un
de spécialement violent pas du tout
assez tallinn pour pratiquement pas
sortir c'était très rare pour faire ses
courses avec ce simple ce qu'ils avaient
vu une dame qui venait pour faire leur
ménagerie